non-minimalists can you discuss
how we should approach the leap between
decluttering
and simplifying to live a meaningful
life
or a life with purpose yeah so so leo
let's talk about this
uh the leap between decluttering and
simplifying so we'll just call it
decluttering
uh to living a life with purpose so we
kind of touched on that a moment ago
because
i think here's here's something that's
confusing for folks
they think well minimalism i'm just
going to get rid of my
stuff and then all of a sudden it's
perpetual bliss
sure that i'm going to live a manic life
of
of always 10 out of 10 happiness
contentment joy
pleasure and that's not my experience at
least
yeah you already have over 140
characters by the way
sean's a good editor we're good okay i
have something pithy for you but i just
want to get
your thoughts first yeah um for me
what happened was i used simplifying and
decluttering to
clear some space to really start to
explore
what my purpose was so i didn't i didn't
have that at first i wasn't clear
but i i had the breathing room now and i
can now start to get closer to myself
and what what matters to me
hmm let's talk about what it kind of
looked like when you started letting go
of some stuff there's obviously that
freeing feeling you feel lighter
um but what what else did you notice as
you st
if you if you tap back to 2005 2006 2007
you're letting go of stuff
what what did you feel in your life was
there an uncertainty there
before i started or when i was starting
as you were as you were letting go yeah
yeah
um the part that that led me into it or
the
or the like what the process felt like
as you were letting go of of excess
stuff and you started questioning things
in your life
what kind of feelings did you have and
did that include any uncertainty
i i actually felt incredible liberation
like it was like so freeing i'm sure you
guys can relate to for sure
that at some points but uh yeah i loved
it and i was like oh
what else can i get rid of so it's just
like this adventure of like oh
this and this and like let's clear out
the whole you know
family room now and uh and then i
the other experience the uncertainty
that actually came up for me was around
my family and they're like whoa whoa
let's put the brakes on a little bit
right um don't get rid of my stuff
and i'm like okay um so let me slow down
now and like
uh play with that so it was it was uh
the uncertainty
um i really enjoyed the uncertainty of
like what would life be like
so it was a question what would life be
like without all this excess stuff
and i i could like even feel as i was
doing it there's more breathing room for
me
um but the uncertainty really was when i
started to meet up against my family
yeah which was actually the like i said
the most rich
area it's easy when you're like a
bachelor as you guys
know like yeah right well i get to
decide right
yeah um but when you're not and you're
in a relationship like that's
that's for me where the real uncertainty
came up for sure yeah i'm going to put
the answer for you right all right and
let's see what this uh if this comports
with yours uh conforms with yours
decluttering won't give you a purpose
but it just might uncover a more
meaningful life
and so that's my my tweet-worthy version
of what we're talking about here ryan
what do you got for us that's good um
you know uh before i read this pet the
answer i do want to say like when i
first
decluttered so i sold my condo i got rid
of my car payment i moved into a
smaller place um got my bills you know
from like
5 000 a month to like a thousand i mean
it was just like
really really simplifying and it felt
good to be there but man when i was
alone
and when i had all that breathing room
it was uncomfortable like i wish i could
just be like yeah i simplified my life
and now i'm happy
but it was this process of really
understanding what it meant
to me to live a purpose-filled life to
to live a meaningful life
and uh what it really turns out to be is
you know changing the relationships that
i had in my life like that's
really where i kind of started getting
ideas on what i wanted to do
so my pithy answer is this to live a
purposeful life
surround yourself with purpose-filled
people
and i'll tell you when i started to hang
around people who were living
a meaningful life who were simplifying
it was just a great
um batch of recipes to kind of choose
ingredients from and it helped me to
help me to like really choose how to
move forward
yeah i think there were a lot of you
know toxic relationships in both of our
lives oh yeah or early on i don't know
if you experienced any of that leo but
with us and even the ones that weren't
toxic they may have been toxic for us
you know how some people can have the uh
are allergic to certain foods right
like ryan can eat a a gluten sandwich or
a fine
bucket of nails yeah and he'll be fine
for me if i
you know if i eat certain things it
really messes me up and i think the same
is true with our relationship sometimes
it's not that the other person's toxic
it's that the relationship can be
toxic it's just not not working out for
whatever reason and many of our
relationships i felt
early on especially back in the
corporate world they were birthed out of
proximity or convenience right it's like
oh we happen to
work in the same on the same floor in
our offices
next to each other but we didn't share
similar values we didn't share similar
interests we just had
a career that coincided for that period
of time but
i was spending 90 of my time with people
like that and forsaking the people
closest to me as a result